- Um...
(speaking French)
(upbeat music)
- (speaking French)
- (speaking French) Jenny.
Shit.
- (speaking French) Sasha.
(speaking French) I am from Toronto.
- I don't remember how to say "I'm from,"
but I'm from Vancouver,
Canada, which explains
my horrible French.
- (speaking French)
- And as soon as I
graduated with my bilingual
certificate, I have not
spoken a word of French.
- I know this one, probably
the only one I know.
- (speaking French)
(speaking French)
- I'll just like wing this one.
- (speaking French)
- I honestly don't remember any of these.
- I feel like my diplomas from high school
are gonna get like revoked.
- (speaking French), uh...
- (speaking French)
- I remember cat, but
I don't remember dog.
- (speaking French), is
it (speaking French)?
- (speaking French) Tucker.
- This is so bad, I only
know Tucker (laughing).
- That's like grade one French.
- (speaking French) for hat.
- (speaking French), I think.
- Shall we pretend that these are pants
and make (speaking French)?
- Can I like, (speaking French)?
- I don't think I know
how to spell it though.
- As an English person,
like when you're taking
French tests, you learn
to like cheat a bit.
- (speaking French)
- The answer was always no.
- The only sentence I
remember is (speaking French),
which I used a lot.
Oh my god, I don't know.
- (speaking French)
- Oh my god, I don't
remember any of the verbs.
- Sorry, all those French classes
meant nothing apparently (laughing).
- (speaking French)
- I'm sorry for my French
teachers who spent that time.
- Is it (speaking French)?
- I feel like I'm a
disgrace to Canada right now
and I'm sorry.
- Such a shame, a waste of
12 years of studying French.
- Like I'm from Quebec
and the thing is like
(speaking French).
(Speaking French) nothing.